[Música]
pues una vida dedicado a la amazonas
es más varias vidas yo vengo de una
familia que ha dedicado ya cuatro
generaciones a luchar por la diversidad
el derecho a ser diferente en el derecho
a pensar diferente mi bisabuelo en
alemania de donde viene mi familia
originalmente que se nota
él luchó contra el nazismo y lo
descargaron el enemigo número uno del
partido nazi durante la segunda guerra
mis abuelos por un lado estuvieron en la
resistencia y llegaron a colombia a
hacer cofundadores de la universidad de
los andes y por el otro lado mi abuelo y
mi abuela también dedicaron su vida y
montaron el primer departamento de
antropología en colombia
mi papá aunque está ahí y yo de chiquito
en amazonas ha dedicado su vida y la
siga dedicando por los derechos
indígenas y los territorios indígenas
y yo crecí en un mundo cuando llegaba el
colegio hacer las tareas me sentaba era
escuchar historias y mitos de las
amazonas
a escuchar una colombia desde un punto
de vista diferente a ver cómo se pueden
hacer preguntas de formas diferentes
encontrar respuestas de formas
diferentes porque no hay una sola
cultura que tenga las respuestas a todas
las preguntas y esta es una cosa que a
mí me impactó de chiquito en el fondo
del corazón porque yo creo desde lo más
profundo en mí que es en la diversidad
que nos complementamos como humanidad
que no hay respuesta en un solo lugar
bueno una sola ciencia bueno una sola
forma de creencia y que tenemos que
abrir el pensamiento para aprender a
escucharnos e inspirarnos y ahí es donde
encontramos el poder de la innovación
por eso yo he dedicado a mi vida también
a continuar trabajando con los pueblos
indígenas para proteger a las amazonas
para proteger este planeta que nos
mantiene vivos
este es un mapa de la nasa que es
bastante fantástico que es un mapa donde
se ve como el agua se transporta
alrededor del mundo en las nubes como
van moviéndose parte por la rotación de
la tierra pero en gran parte también
porque los bosques tropicales en
particular la el amazonas' funcionan
como grandes bombas de agua que están
chupando el aire y la humedad es del
atlántico pasando a través de todas las
zonas hasta llegar a los páramos de la
patagonia y eso es porque los árboles
cuando cae el agua absorben el agua y la
sueltan evaporan el agua con pequeñas
partículas partículas que crean nubes en
otras palabras los árboles son como
grandes fábricas de nubes que están
alimentando y regando estos ríos
voladores que llevan más agua desde el
atlántico hacia los andes' que toda el
agua que está por el río amazonas en
dirección contraria
carga más agua que el río más grande del
planeta tierra estos ríos voladores para
mí es impresionante las imágenes ahí
como se ve casi un pálpito uno puede ver
ese amazonas cómo va cambiando de color
llegó a través de las diferentes épocas
del año que van cargando las nubes e ir
regando toda américa de lo cual depende
el 70 por ciento del producto interno el
producto interno bruto de américa latina
depende de este río volador y el agua
que tomamos en la casa y la comida con
la que nos alimentamos la energía con la
que nos iluminamos depende de este río
volador de poco sirve tener -dijo-
eléctricas si no cuidamos esa agua como
llega hasta sus fuentes
entonces siempre hay tres partes del río
volador amazónico en la parte sur que es
en la parte sur de la cuenca que esa
parte ya la de foresta mos básicamente
es arribó al área se nos fue y es por
eso que vemos en brasil también en el
sur de la amazonía los incendios
ciudades como sao paulo que tienen 16
millones de personas y que se ha quedado
sin agua
el río central que está casi en un punto
de no retorno tiene unas presiones y
unas amenazas tan fuertes que en verdad
ver cómo podemos mantenerlo en pie es un
reto que de pronto se nos está saliendo
de las manos para las buenas noticias
que el río del norte todo lo que está en
la parte norte del río amazonas hacia
arriba ese es el último y tercer río
volador que está en pie que sigue
funcionando donde hay un altísimo nivel
de conservación amazónica de los bosques
tropicales y que todavía tenemos la
oportunidad de mantenerlo para el futuro
este es el plan c y no hay plan de y
todos dependemos de esto el amazona lo
tenemos en la casa todos los días y es
curioso porque muchas veces como
colombianos nos imaginamos en la zona es
algo por allá en leticia y el 42% de
paises amazonía tenemos la diversidad
cultural y lingüística más alta del
planeta esta zona de la amazonía
colombiana con brasil y venezuela- es
donde está la mayor diversidad biológica
cultural y lingüística del planeta y por
ende también
las formas de entender los problemas y
la diversidad de entender el mundo de
encontrar soluciones más diversas del
planeta es un tesoro que tenemos ahí
ahora un problema es que esta es parte
de la realidad que seguimos viendo no
una amazonas en llamas y en colombia en
particular también en los últimos cinco
años se ha abierto las puertas a la
amazonía con los intereses públicos y
privados de una manera arrasadora el 40
por ciento en deforestación que se está
dando un acaparamiento de tierras
básicamente comiéndose la amazonía para
entrar la en venta la minería ni hablar
de la minería que se ha metido
programación y a profunda y que hoy
tenemos los índices de mercurio más
altos de toda colombia en comunidades
indígenas donde nunca llega un teléfono
y eso lo hemos logrado en los últimos 10
años entonces el nivel de presiones y el
nivel de retos que tenemos es fuerte
esta es la cuenca amazónica en
latinoamérica con la amazonía es
importante también ver que la amazona
funciona como uno solo los ríos
voladores nos muestran cómo depende y si
no rompe una parte del río volador
rompió todo el mecanismo no hasta cuando
le podemos ir sacando piezas a un motor
antes de que el motor pare de funcionar
y esa la pregunta que tenemos acá por
eso no se trata simplemente de ver un
poquito de deforestación aquí o un
poquito de minería ya un poquito de
carreteras acá si vemos la amazonía como
una sola veamos los problemas también
los retos también como uno solo y si
juntamos los que vimos la deforestación
la minería si juntamos con las
carreteras con el petróleo con el gas
los ponemos todos juntos y le tomamos
una foto este es el nivel del reto que
tenemos hoy en día frente a la amazonía
lo que ven en rojo son las presiones de
hoy son las cosas que están sucediendo
lo que viene en rosado son unas cosas
que todavía podemos evitar
y cuando les hable de los ríos voladores
en esta parte norte de acá si ven gran
gran parte de las presiones aún la
podemos evitar
y aún más donde pasa este último río
volador el 70 por ciento de ese
territorio son territorios indígenas y
los indígenas son absolutamente claves a
la hora son fundamentales a la hora de
proteger al amazonas primero que todo
porque son los que han llamado al
amazonas toda su vida desde hace 10.000
años su hogar porque tienen un
conocimiento ancestral y milenario de
cómo proteger a las amazonas y estar en
verdad en una relación con el amazonas
cuando se estaban sacando los resguardos
y se hablaba de la titulación de
resguardos para muchos de los líderes
era algo casi incomprensible que como
así que manejar un papel que yo soy
bueno y un resguardo cuando el
territorio de perteneces a los pajaritos
ya las aves ya los peces nosotros le
pertenecemos al territorio que es este
concepto que tenemos de propiedad tan
nocivo
y también cuando yo hace en el 2006 me
fui a vivir al mini paraná que queda ya
en el departamento del amazonas de fito
lo que yo pensaba que era tres meses me
quedé un año y medio viviendo monte
adentro con las comunidades los stand y
nunca los jonas le tua más los mata pin
y yo fui también con ciertas ideas un
poquito de lo que yo me imaginaba que
era el manejo ambiental de las
comunidades yo me imaginaba pues manejo
ambiental comunitario pues debe ser de
un ámbito comunitario que manejan las
lagunas donde están los peces o donde
están los recursos alrededor no podría
estar más equivocado apenas me senté con
los chamanes con los sabedores y con las
sabedoras empecé a ver que es que el
manejo que tiene me empezaban a narrar
de los sitios de manejo especial los
sitios de importancia biológica desde
las bocas del río amazonas por donde
pasaron hace más de 15 mil años y te van
narrando lugar por lugar te van de
iguana el mapa de la cuenca y empiezas a
darte cuenta que es que el manejo que
tiene en su manejo hiper complejo un
manejo regional y de un entendimiento
súper profundo de la interconectividad
que hay entre un lugar y el otro en
verdad si alguien tiene claro que la
amazona funciona como uno si alguien
tiene claro los ríos voladores si
alguien tiene claro todo esto son los
pueblos indígenas
el conocimiento que tienen los pueblos
indígenas simplemente no los podemos
ignorar
tenemos que abrir el pèndol a la mente
para empezar a sentarnos con los que
piensan diferente y entender que es a
partir de la diversidad que podemos
construir podemos tener estas formas de
pensar en conflicto o en diálogo
y eso es a lo que me he dedicado toda la
vida también compras con la fundación
gaia hacer puentes entre el mundo
indígena y el mundo indígena apoyar a
las comunidades a investigar ellos
mismos dentro de sus propios
conocimientos tradicionales cómo
funciona esa ciencia que está codificada
en los mitos en las historias de las
narrativas cómo funciona ese manejo
ambiental que han pulido a través de
miles de años cómo hacer para que no lo
explican para que nosotros entendamos
ellos lo tienen claro ellos ya ellas
nosotros somos los que no tenemos claro
cómo llevar desde el espacio cultural y
el espacio ritual a construir políticas
y propuestas concretas para que pueblos
indígenas y estados puedan construir
conjuntamente eso le hemos dedicado
desde los ochentas han sido procesos que
han involucrado cientos de jóvenes
hombres mujeres sabedores y sabedoras de
más de 25 grupos étnicos desde los 80s
hemos logrado apoyar la titulación de 25
millones de hectáreas es el territorio
indígena más continuo más grande del
mundo
y hemos apoyado 25 grupos étnicos en
este proceso en formalizar sus gobiernos
locales en construir propuestas
ambientales pero a partir de su
conocimiento tradicional no llevar
respuestas no imponer mi nombre de la
ciencia en el nombre de nadie como
pensar es como abrir puentes para
abrirnos el pensamiento y empezar a
escucharnos e inspirarnos
se ha logrado muchísimo un poco se sabe
en colombia también de hecho estos
procesos en la más unidad colombiana son
el referente a nivel internacional
zona referente cuando se habla de los
trabajos del manejo ambiental liderado
por indígenas de los gobiernos indígenas
de verdad el empoderamiento político a
partir de la identidad propia y el
conocimiento propio colombia está a años
luz comparado con cualquier otro país de
la cuenca amazónica o de áfrica o de
asia y son el referente y nos invitan a
dar talleres en diferentes países y todo
el mundo medida como el modelo a seguir
y esto es algo que no estamos ni
enterados en colombia no sabemos de lo
que está pasando y es una cosa cambia
parece preocupante porque la amazona se
está bajo una presión alarmante pero hay
30 años de procesos entre gobierno y
pueblos indígenas súper fuertes hay
miles de años de conocimiento los
indígenas están poniendo su parte están
poniendo su conocimiento su territorio
pero esta es una responsabilidad que
desde todos
y en verdad si queremos proteger ese
último río volador del amazonas
necesitamos involucrarnos todos como
país hay un cuento para ilustrar un
poquito hace años me fui con tres
chamanes nos fuimos al medio oriente un
intercambio que había
y después de pasar varias semanas por
allá en la opulencia del medio oriente y
todo estábamos en el carro de regreso y
los tres semanas estaban hablando entre
ellos para ver qué pasa me dije no auan
a buenas mi nombre para acá agua nácar y
es el nombre con el que me utilizaron en
amazonas y me dicen no aguanta tranquila
no es nada dije no pero cuente que es un
nuevo paso es que
[Música]
la gente es tan pobre
como nuestra gente es tan pobre tan
pobre ellos sólo tienen plata
nosotros tenemos la cultura la identidad
del río los peces los pájaros tenemos y
comienzan a nombrar todo lo que hay
y eso lo lleva uno en verdad a
cuestionarse en el corazón qué es lo que
estamos valorando a qué le estamos
apostando acá voltearon agua llegó a la
amazonía es perder el mantenimiento
también de la vida para latinoamérica
pero también como la apostamos a una
diversidad biológica la riqueza que hay
debemos estar orgullosos de lo que hemos
mantenido de lo que hemos logrado
podríamos darle voz a las más zonas voz
a los ríos voladores y esto nos
compromete a todos desde las
universidades desde el activismo desde
involucrarse personalmente y
directamente en estos procesos pero aquí
todos estamos metidos en este bote nadie
lo puede hacer sobre ni los indígenas lo
pueden hacer solo en el estado de la
sociedad civil
entonces quería simplemente pues
venir a contarles un poco cómo tenemos a
la mano una gran oportunidad de mantener
este último río volador del amazonas'
vivo
y 2 es parte de todos nosotros como
podemos abrir nuestros pensamientos
acercarnos a los que piensan diferente
sentarnos a hablar entre todos y a
partir de la diversidad unidos en la
diversidad construir una amazona de un
futuro
muchas gracias